this will be our initial example for
something that works so let's define s
to be now no this is not s n it's not a
classical song this thing is going to go
for it love okay I'm going to start at
half this time you will see why later on
I'm gonna start off rather than one like
I've been studying at all different and
I'm going to make my ratio also a half
okay so every time is getting half the
size of the previous one okay now I'm
just going to do a tiny little segue
here tell you this thing right and I
want to point out something which seems
like it would be why this works but in
fact it's not and I'll probably do with
in period three robbing him about
working now do you see let's uh let's
pour this language over here right do
you notice that one of the main
differences between all of these series
that don't work and this series that
does is that the limit as n approaches
infinity of each individual term just
the individual terms
what's that limit going towards middle
quarter of zero length 16 they're
clearly going toward zero right in fact
that is kind of behaving like this oh
the faster because rally going
one two three four five on the
denominator I'm going to two four eight
sixteen on the denominator does that
make sense so each individual term is
doing what this is doing so it's going
towards zero now you might think that's
enough to make this converge right just
like this does right but in fact that
property alone is not enough
insufficient it looks like it's enough
but it's mom and later on I'll prove one
okay what I really want is I need some
help from the partial sum okay so this
is the whole thing but I want a snapshot
of what's happening at each point in
time and then I'm really gonna see
what's happening because then you know
this is what my definition of the whole
series was it's the limit of the
partials
who's going so first turn feedback to
your offensive definition right s what
is just equal to turn one which is a
half when you add a quarter to that
that's your second term coming along to
the ride a half is two quarters so you
add one quarter on so you're going to
get speakers then you're going to get
when you add an eighth phone to that 7/8
okay good now I actually from here
remember three terms is enough to
establish a pattern for any sequence
even if it's not an LP or a GP right
what's happening
what would SN what would that look like
hmm have a look you can't believe look
at the numbers yeah right for example
have a look at two and four and then
eight where are these numbers coming
from in relation to n 2 1 2 & 3 there
they're the corresponding powers of 2
right do you see that maybe the
consequent pazu 2 is the is the first
power of 2 4 is the second pair up to 8
is the third power - yep so on the
denominator what do I have and 2 to the
power of n are you content with that yes
on the numerator I always have exactly 1
less than that right you can go to the
next one will be 15 and 16 and 31 and 32
and so on so I've got 2 to the N minus 1
all right now I want to think here by
definition by definition s is equal to
the limit as n approaches infinity of
this thing right s so if I take the
limit of a left-hand side I've been take
the limit of the right-hand side limit
as n approaches infinity of this thing 2
to the N minus 1 okay
now just get your head back in a limit
land right for a second at the moment I
cannot just simply evaluate this limit
just like with first principles you
can't
putting H equals zero why can't I do
that at least not yet yeah this thing's
going to blow up and this thing's gonna
blow up okay and so I've got kind of in
a way the-- I've got infinity over
infinity and the problem we think about
something like that saying oh why isn't
it just equal to
they're both infinity why is it just
equal one the answer is well there are
different kinds of infinity okay um I'm
not going to make a big argue about it
now but there are different kinds so you
can't just simply evaluate but we used
to do some algebraic trick student
unlike with first principles if we did
something like this do you remember if I
was differentiating say the square root
X this is what I get what we do to that
thing
in order to let us evaluate at H equals
zero what did I have to do what
algebraic trick declare my pocket I've
rationalized the numerator
it's a bit unusual right but once you do
that that H we can disappear off the
denominator and you're fine right
what would my do here yeah I've got one
fraction which is usually a good thing
but I'm gonna break apart because then I
can evaluate right so this left-hand
side by definition is s and then on the
right hand side I still have limits but
what I get is to the N onto the end
which is one takeaway one on two to the
n ah now I've got something I can do
okay infinity or infinity that's a
problem but one or infinity I know
exactly what that does that does this if
I thought that's exactly what it does
right so it doesn't even faster so now I
have an answer key up right this is one
takeaway zero I'm gonna write that
takeaway zero in because it shows I know
what's happening to this rather than it
just being you disappeared okay
so s equal one alright come on in a
second what are we saying we're saying
that this series up here huh
this quarter plus
all the way if you add up an infinite
number of terms now the flash or summer
purchased one so I define this thing
inverted commas the whole series if you
can put infinity in your hair I defined
it to be 1 this thing gets a name okay
this thing it's really a limit do you
see that and it's kind of the limit of
all the partial sums they can't get any
further than one so therefore what I
call this and this would be your head in
two I call this the limiting some
limiting some do you see it's all about
limits question you mean why am I
thinking that these guys well I define
where I'm looking five according to this
according to limits not according to
what I the ground is there so I could
look at any part of like for example on
the same grounds I could say within as n
approaches maybe money and I can pick up
the limit as n approaches zero and I can
think about and so on so so bad I want
to take the connection too
sumit why didn't you go approach the the
Fields Medal committee feels metals the
mathematical killer the Nobel Prize I
can make that suggestion to say I would
love to see that the dog okay okay so
he's all we going to do
you remember I said this is an
interesting series so what I want to do
is I want to try and convince you of
this but in a less formal way and well I
think is very appealing and I heard will
for you and then we will generalize this
result okay so remember I said I started
a half rounds with one why did that dude
bad okay here's why I want you to
imagine and up in fact I just imagine I
want you to draw with me a square make
it reasonable size and let's imagine
that this square has a side that's a
terrible script anyway as a side length
of one okay if it has a side length of
one what's the area of this square 1 by
1 which is 1 thumbs up so far okay
Square Center view okay what square unit
so so the area of this square is 1 okay
now I can find within this square and in
fact there are lots of um series ideas I
can find this series in this square how
would these if these were areas right
how might they appear within my swear
yeah like a4 paper is twice the size of
a5 paper which is the twice the size of
a c6 paper and so on okay so I'm gonna
do something similar here but not quite
sure if I have my 1 meter square
one unit and I divide it in half and I'd
like you to divide it as well
on the left hand side here and the right
hand side has two rectangles because
tell the middle equal area so what's the
area of this rectangle over here it's a
lot okay now now I can have the first
term there I have the second term as
well I'm gonna take this rectangle over
here and I will also divide it in half I
hope you can see why I'm dividing it off
right because that's the common ratio so
that's how I'm gonna geometrically
geometrically GP that's how I'm gonna do
this okay how am I gonna get Nathan here
I'm going to take this accordance left
over I'll turbine this guy as well now
you can do this next construction you
know in a variety of ways but he's my
favorite wakes I think it looks the best
okay um this whatever the shape is
leftover if I keep what is this thing
what's happening here if I keep on
subdividing notice if I subdivide
forever right and I have to do it
forever because if I stop at any
arbitrary point even if it's like N
equals a million right there will still
be a tiny little spot that I haven't
covered right but if I go forever then
the sum of all of these individual areas
namely 1/2 plus 1/4 same and so on the
sum of all of the areas combined is just
equal to the original square right like
I will have the whole square covered
provided I can to infinity right so
that's a nice visual way of
demonstrating and there are lots of
other visual ways go look up a look up a
book online called proofs without words
which is where I go this wrong it's a
classic way to demonstrate this is equal
to one this is another really depressing
way that talked about a frog that's
really far away from let's not
it's one meter away from water and for
some reason he gets like dying of thirst
so he's like progressively more tired
every time he jumps so you can only jump
half of the distance that he sees in
front of him which is really a morbid
way to demonstrate this a tremendous way
well no not only apparently he saw me
and tired but he's also very good at
measuring